remember that the david pakman show is
made
possible by members who sign up
at joinpackman.com everyone
is very very special let's go
to the phone lines at davidpakman.com
discord starting with uh oh i don't know
let's start with
let's start with dj from montana dj from
montana you're on the air
uh hi david how are you can you hear me
yes i can i'm doing great uh my name is
david tu
um i am gonna pay my subscription in two
days and i couldn't be more proud and i
just wondered if you could tell everyone
something that that drives you to do
what you do uh maybe there's an event or
a person in the past
that's all thanks no there is no such
event or person i hate i mean it's
you know we i want to inform the people
i want people engaged i want people
uh committing to things that are
important to that to them it's not up
for
to me to tell you what what that should
be but hopefully to let you know that
there are things happening in the world
that you should be paying attention to
and that your involvement is
um uh a good thing and that we should
all aspire to
get involved but there i sadly have no
um
black swan event i can point to uh david
well that's okay thanks for your time
all right very good and we will welcome
that membership payment with wide open
arms as you can imagine